drifting in but uh let's go ahead and
get started uh first of all some
practical things uh
so the first talk's gonna be by dick
carp and i'll give him a brief
introduction in a minute but i want to
say some practical things first um
so first of all um there's a if you
haven't attended the meetings before
the talks are going to last about 35 or
40 minutes and then there's about 15
minutes for
discussion but the discussion can also
be interspersed with the talks if you
want to ask questions in the middle
if you want to ask questions uh please
type into the chat windows
and uh you either have a q a window if
you're an attendee or you have a chat
window if you're a
panelist if you do type into the chat
window as a panelist
you're encouraged to pick the option to
send your chat
to all panelists and attendees that's
not the default the default is to just
all
panelists so that everyone will have the
benefit to see your
uh comments and i'll be watching the
chat windows and
possibly will interrupt the speaker with
questions
depending on how the talk is going and
how i'm feeling at that moment
so so let's see
dick is not going to use any overhead
transparency so you might want to pick
the speaker view on zoom it's up in the
upper right hand corner of your
window and otherwise we're about ready
to get start
started on their first speaker is
richard carp he's a
great we have two very distinguished
speakers of course and um
i was just gonna so we're not gonna say
too much here uh
uh uh he's been at berkeley since
approximately
i say 1968 with a short break in the
middle
he was the founding director for the
simon's institute as well he's
won numerous awards and prizes which i'm
not going to list
but i wanted to mention his 1972
land land landmark paper on reducibility
among common tutorial problems which
along with
steve cook's paper the prior year was
one of the ones that really
set the foundations for the modern study
of the theory of computer science
with the pn p questions and so on um
and so i believe he's going to be
talking about things around that topic
today
the title of his talk is the dawn of
computational complexity
and i think go ahead
thank you okay uh hello everybody i hope
you can hear me it's good to see you
those that i can see um
let's go back to 1971 in 1971
uh steve uh cook proved
that if sat is in p
then p is equal to np
this audience is probably entirely
familiar with all of the terminology in
that statement but just for the record
let's go through it
um p is of course the we're dealing
first of all with decision problems
where the uh input is a string of
symbols over a finite
alpha alphabet representing some
mathematical structure
and the task of the algorithm
is to either accept or reject any
particular
input um
p is the class of uh deterministic
problem solvable
in polynomial time by deterministic
algorithms
um np is the class solvable in
polynomial time by non-deterministic
algorithms a more illuminating
description of
np is to say that
in np um
the problem is is to um
exit to
test whether a particular string called
a witness
actually with this is the
reception of the input um
so um
class np uh consists of
a a very wide class of problems
including
virtually all of the typical
optimization problems arise that arise
in applications
and it seems to be
a much much broader than p
where the requirement is not just to
recognize an input but to accept uh
make a decision about input strings
so uh intuitively we are inclined to
believe
that p is unequal to np
because it appears that
solving a typical problem in np entails
an exponential search
but this is unproven and it is a
central problem in complexity theory
later in the talk we'll uh talk about
other problems that can play the same
role as
satisfiability uh
namely uh so we'll say that problem x
is np-complete if we can make the
inference that
if x is in p then p is equal to np
and those np-complete problems are
considered to be
the hardest problems in the class np
uh so i'll return to uh cook's theorem
and its consequences a little bit later
in the talk but right now what i want to
do
rather than a talk that looks toward the
future as you might expect
in such a conference uh i'll be looking
to the past and trying to give you
a view of the experiences i had starting
in 1959
after just after my phd at harvard going
to the
ibm research center and the developments
that i witnessed
between 1959 and 1971 the
date of cook's paper
so in 1959 there was no complexity
theory there was one
somewhat sketchy think piece by michael
raven but
really not much else
but there was a certain amount of work
on combinatorial algorithms
uh in particular uh george densig
had uh created the simplex algorithm for
solving
linear programming the problem of
minimizing or maximizing a linear
function of
n variables subject to linear inequality
constraints
uh this algorithm was immensely valuable
and highly reliable in practice but it
was known
that it was not a polynomial time
algorithm in fact
there were instances known that would
cause it to run for exponential time
so the pedigree of the simplex algorithm
was not entirely clear despite
its actual effectiveness in practice
um another early result that was
influential
was the work of raven and scott
on finite automata where they introduced
the
notion of a non-deterministic algorithm
non-deterministic finite automaton
in that case and uh that concept of
uh non-determinism uh uh
has turned out to be essential in
the uh in complexity theory
there are also a number of uh
algorithmic
developments i'll mention a few uh
related to
uh graphs in particular
as early as 1926 berifka had given a
fast algorithm for
a minimum spanning tree
they were algorithms for computing
shortest paths and graphs
flows and cuts in networks
computing the testing whether a graph
was strongly connected
etc people at the time were not very
rigorous about
estimating the running time of an
algorithm they
were sort of more intuitive as to
whether the algorithms seemed good to
them
and so for example
ford and fulkerson who created the max
flow min cut theorem
never bothered to check whether the max
flow algorithm that they gave ran in
polynomial time
and in fact as stated it did not
although it could be fixed
to run in polynomial time as jack
edmonds and i
uh later showed
so there was a certain amount of
looseness about
estimating the time and in particular
there wasn't much
sophistication about data structures
that came along later
where very inventive data structures
were created to whittle down the running
time of some of these algorithms to
close to linear time
bob tarjan was a leading architect of
that kind of data structure work
so um
were certain problems that were cons
that were viewed
as um as hard although there was
this was based on just
the inability to solve them rapidly
rather than any theoretical
considerations
and so in particular um george dunsic
the creator of the simplex algorithm um
felt that the integer programming
problem was a good candidate for
being the central or quintessential
problem to which others
to to which many applications could be
mapped
so um you recall that linear programming
problem
is to find the
highest point on a polytope in
international space
um uh the simplex method
uh attacks this problem by walking
on an increasing path along edges of the
polytope until it can't improve anymore
the integer programming problem is a
related one
it's the linear programming problem plus
the requirement
that the variables be integers
and that makes the problem uh much
tougher
but there's a an approach called the
cutting plane approach which seems to be
uh quite powerful in solving integer
programming problems the idea is the
following
uh
the uh as we say if we ignore the
uh integrality constraints then we get
the linear programming problem
um of minimizing linear function over a
polytope
with the requirement that the variables
be integers
we restrict the feasible region not to
that polytope
but to the vertices of
the convex hull of the integer solutions
so it's a politic so we're working with
a
polytope uh inside the
one arising in the fractional problem
and so the idea of a cutting plane
approach
is to solve the fractional problem
and then devise a
linear inequality which is
satisfied by uh
all of the integer solutions to the
problem
and and add that inequality thereby
cutting off part of the polytope
and so the cutting claim method proceeds
by
slicing away at the linear programming
polytope
until a contained polytope is
obtained whose highest point is integral
and this technique
does work well in many cases but without
real guarantees my colleague dan
gustfield has said
always try integer programming it might
work
so uh a notable result
around 1960 was due to ralph gomery
who showed that a particular variant of
the cutting plane method
uh actually uh terminated with an
optimal solution
although he could not give any uh bounds
on the
running time of the algorithm the number
of iterations of cutting that would
be required
further evidence for the cutting plane
approach was
provided by dancing fulkerson and
johnson
who solved a pro
a traveling salesman problem over
through where the cities are the uh
state capitals of the continental u.s
states plus
the state of the city of washington dc
so it was a 49 city problem
which they solved by the cutting plane
method
solved efficiently by the cutting plane
method
this approach was taken up by taken up
further
by uh applegate cook kavatal
and bixby who uh
tried to apply it to the travel and
salesman problem
so the idea there is to start with a
linear programming relaxation of the
traveling salesman problem and then
to hack away at it with cutting planes
until
an optimal integer solution is obtained
but it the uh
the traveling salesman probably can be
formally
related as finding a minimum total cost
set of edges of a graph
where the vertices are the cities
subject to the requirement that two
edges have chosen each incident with
each vertex
and for each partition non-empty
partition of the
set of cities in two parts uh at least
two edges must run
between the two parts
so the linear programming problem is uh
which is being relaxed is to
[Music]
imitate those constraints but with now
fractional weights on the edges
so that for example instead of having
two edges out of the edge you
have many edges with fractional
participation summing
two and
amazing results were obtained in
using the cutting plane method uh
starting with that
linear programming uh relaxation
and hacking away at the polytope
um and problems with as many as
80 000 cities were solved although with
an extravagant
computing requirement
meanwhile uh still in the
early to mid 60s uh we saw
the beginnings of complexity theory
there was a fascinating uh formulation
of complexity theory
um in an axiomatic way by emanuel blum
where instead of
measuring the computational resource as
time or space it was any resource
satisfying a certain natural constraint
um and blum working in in that axiomatic
approach was able to prove amazing
theorems such as the fact that
um there exist algorithms which use
time or space or any related resource
so much that every
there's a problem such that
every algorithm for the problem can be
improved exponentially
no matter how many times you iterate the
improvement you keep getting
exponential improvement and there are
other fascinating results but the one
that was the
approach that was um
perhaps more lasting in its effects was
started by
heart manus and sterns which studied the
resources of time and space on the
turing machine
and defined complexity classes
accordingly improved hierarchy theorems
showing that a little bit of increase in
the available time
or in the available space allows a
larger set of problems to be solved
and they actually looked at other things
like
simulating a two tape more turing
machine on a single type machine
and other simulation results
so this work was very influential in
getting complexity theory
off to its start but
a more revolutionary approach was to
focus on the boundary between polynomial
time and
non-polynomial time and
this approach was
advocated by alan cobham
who wrote a paper where he described
defined the class
that we now call p um explained why it
was important
that uh it was a reasonable theoretical
formulation of the notion of
efficient solvability to say that a
problem is in that class
uh he even hinted at the definition of
np
and this rather prescient result
was um
was hardly noted by the community
uh i never heard about it at the time
and in fact i never met cobham
although we worked in the same large
industrial laboratory
but he could be credited with the first
one to publicly
reference the importance of the class p
uh sometime in the mid 60s um
i began collaborating with jack edmonds
uh we did some work on network flow
problems on uh
matching problems on uh the
uh the uh
the problem of uh uh pairing up
uh boys and girls so as to minimize the
total benefit of all of the pairings
the so-called assignment problem and we
improved the time bounds for some of
those problems as i mentioned we
gave a polynomial time bound for a
variant of
of max flow but more important than the
research we did together
from my point of view at least was the
opportunity to
visit jack at his workplace at the
national bureau of standards
and allow him to give me a discourse on
the wonderful results he was obtaining
polynomial time algorithms for the
non-bipartite matching problem
for
for metroid intersection for uh
um
for other uh problems other graph
theoretic problems
uh where he showed that that these
problems were
uh in uh p um
but also noted in passing that they were
an np intersect co-np
and uh it led him to to
the conjecture not yet disproven
that uh p is equal to np intersect co np
um but i i was again strongly influenced
by
jack's approach with the emphasis on
polynomial time algorithms
um and
his his ideas were at the centerpiece of
most of the graduate courses that i
taught for a number of years
on combinatorial optimization
in one of those courses silvio mccauley
and vijay vasirani were
first year graduate students that were
taking the course
and i told them in the course about a
result i
obtained with john hopcroft about
maximum matchings in bipartite graphs
showing that you can compute a maximum
matching in time
uh square root of the number of vertices
times
the square of the number of edges square
root of square root of the number of
vertices times the number of edges
into the five halves in other words and
the challenge that i gave them was to
show that the same time bound could be
obtained
for non-bipartite matching which is a
much more difficult problem
and they got excited about this problem
and started working on it avidly totally
forgetting about all of the requirements
of the course that they were sitting in
and as the end of the semester
approached
i had a dilemma because they hadn't done
any of the required work for the course
but they seemed to be getting close to
solving this
problem and so i decided to
give them the highest pass
the lowest passing grade that would
still not get them kicked out of
graduate school
uh a little later i apologize to both of
them for
my rough treatment of them but they they
they didn't seem to
to uh really care
so getting back to uh cook's work
uh i i saw um
his uh 1971 paper
and i had had enough experience with
combinatorial optimization
and combinatorial explosions that
seemed to occur in many of these
problems
that i was i felt certain that
there were many problems that had the
same that that
had more or less the same status as the
satisfiability problem
that they were also in np
and i was convinced that they were
at least as hard as satisfiability and
so
i began to
try to prove that these problems were
what we now call np complete
and the approach to solving them was
based on
polynomial time reductions which are
modeled after the mapping reductions
that have been used in
computability theory to compare
uh the difficulty of different
the computability to solve to prove that
certain problems are undecidable
and the
setup for the polynomial time
reducibility
is the following that if we have two
decision problems a and b each having
input
strings which are either accepted or
rejected
we say that problem a is polynomial time
reducible to problem
b if um
there exists a polynomial time algorithm
whose which maps strings in a
strings in b such that accepted strings
in a
map to accepted strings of b and
rejected the strings
may map to rejected strings in b
and um
it then follows that if problem b is in
the class p
then so is problem a uh
and so the strategy was to start with
the satisfiability problem and give
reductions of this kind gradually
showing more and more problems the
satisfiability problem is reducible to
uh and cinch and and since we also know
from
cook that every one of those that's that
there's a reduction from each of those
to sat we know that all of these
problems uh have the same status they're
either
in p or in np or or not in
ether all in p or either or all
not in p and uh these are called the
uh np complete problems which are
equivalent in this in in the sense of
with respect to membership p although
they're not equivalent in some other
respects and so
the task was to gradually
create reductions from satisfiability
to other problems bringing them into the
mp completeness
uh circle uh
the reductions were not too hard to find
the task was simplified by
um by uh the observation that
uh polynomial time reducibility is a
transitive relation
so if you've already proven that
satisfiability is reducible to problem
x and if x is reducible to y then
satisfiability is reducible to y so with
the help of that observation
uh it was possible to
demonstrate that a large number of
problems 21 in my original paper
we're in we're mp complete
and by now uh using reductions
thousands of problems have been shown to
be
np complete in my reductions i
i tended to not give the sharpest
possible results
so for example i proved that graph
coloring is np
complete but
gary johnson and stockmay prove the much
sharper result
that the three coloring problem for
regular planar graphs of degree 4
is np-complete and similarly with the
hamiltonian circuit problem
instead of just showing that the
hamiltonian circuit problem in general
is np-complete gary johnson and
tarjan showed um that
um it's it's complete even for
a cubic uh three cup
uh three connected planar graphs so much
more refined results were
were obtained and um
thousands of results of that of that
type
were obtained uh there was a flurry of
them in a few years after 1972.
um but eventually it quieted down and
nowadays you can't really
publish a uh an np completeness result
unless the reduction is particularly
clever
um
meanwhile um
there were
there were attempts to
extend to go beyond the setting of p
versus np
and to obtain uh complexity results
uh for higher levels of complexity
um meyer and stockmeyer
um show that
if you if you extend the definition of
regular expression to include the
squaring operator
then you get a problem which requires
exponential
space and they also the same
duo looked at
a decision problem in logic where they
showed that the
for a problem of for an instance of size
610
uh the number of computation steps would
initiative would be required be larger
than the number of protons in the known
universe so um
the techniques of of
uh reduction and
uh for proving complexity bounds
were carried out beyond the level of
the class uh np
um so much
has gone on since uh
1972 including
extensive work on
approximation algorithms for the
combinatorial optimization
versions of of problems
and also magnificent results about
hardness of
computation of approximation
turn my attention back to the
satisfiability problem and make
a couple of remarks so i'm now talking
about
the problem of deciding whether a
formula in a
normal form uh conjunctive normal form
uh is satisfiable
um the
prevalent approaches seem to be to use
either resolution
or the uh
the cdcl approach
in which one starts selecting
literals to to be true
and follow up their implications in
terms of
creation of unit clauses which also have
to be satisfied
until a clash is obtained
um and then going back from the
discovery of that clash to
get it to learn uh a new
new clause to add to the problem um
this seems to me to be these approaches
using resolution and using
the conflicts resolution
um seemed to me to be rather primitive
and i
it's to me amazing
you know with the the approach together
with additional heuristics
to solve problems with millions of
variables
but this seems to be the case and i'm
entirely puzzled by it
i'm also puzzled by other algorithmic
developments that seem to be
outside the scope of complexity theory
as it's
currently practiced
so for example um
there are uh results on
um programs that play chess better than
any human
uh on ai approaches to
labeling algorithms according to
labeling images
recognizing images classifying images
where the results seem to be very good
but there's no
well-defined metric from the point of
view of complexity theory to allow us to
prove things about how hard these
problems reasonably
really are so i think i'll stop at this
point
and uh be happy to take questions
all right thank you so much for rather
inspiring talk i must say it's
very very good and i love also your
final comments so
people can't clap so i'll clap on their
behalf and then we'll have some
questions for you and so on as well
good all right so again uh feel free to
drop questions in the chat windows and
uh
i'll i'll take them probably in the
order they're stated more or less we
already have one question
from karim sakala karen do you want to
do you want to state it or should i read
it for you
you can go ahead and okay
all right so so karen asks the relation
between
linear programming lp and integer linear
programming
ilp is strikingly similar to counter
example
guided restriction refinement in model
checking
linear programming is a sound
abstraction of
ilp and cutting plane serves
as refinements that increase the
precision of abstraction by eliminating
infeasible solutions is this an obvious
connection
and has it been noted before
um i don't think i'm prepared to answer
that
okay okay um let me see
uh if i can phrase that yeah okay well
yeah i mean i think uh cam just
remarking on the fact that at the very
beginning you talked about the
or not close to being talked at length
about integer
programming and the connections to sat
and so on
so um i'm not sure i can answer this
question either just don't ease it okay
um yeah
okay so while people
help people formulate some questions if
i can maybe i ask one of my own while
waiting for people to give some
questions here
i was just was wondering why you were
speaking you were talking about uh
steve cook's 1971 paper and i i believe
you overlapped
in time time wise with with at berkeley
with steve is that correct
and i know steve did seminars on this
on these topics at berkeley is it was
there any interaction or
feedback back in those days but between
the two lines of study uh
no i knew steve very well while he was
at berkeley
and was very saddened by the fact that
he moved to the university of toronto
but i became aware of this i knew of
some of his earlier work from his
thesis at harvard for example but
i only learned about this work by
reading his 1971 paper
so we actually
never discussed those issues um
until i had already absorbed his this
paper
right so it's yeah so it's intriguing
you ended with a comment that
um rat resolution and cdcl are
strikingly
successful and we're lacking complexity
results
for why this is the case do you have any
thoughts about what might
be the right approach to this and so on
well
there have been some complexity results
um
there's a paper by uh
bean mike sachs
another co-author and with me as a
courteous
courtesy co-author because i made one
small status
observation about twosat and somehow
they
stuck my name on the paper um
where they explore the threshold for
random
k sat and how many cl how many
random clauses you need before a boolean
expression
becomes uh unsatisfiable
and uh they derived some some bounds on
that
and of course they're worked by several
people on proof complexity for
the pigeonhole principle and other
particular
formulation particular instances
where they proved to be exponential for
ordinary resolution
um i haven't seen i'm not an expert on
this but i haven't seen
results on
complexity results for cdcl just the
observation
that it seems to work very well on the
problems that arise naturally in
applications
okay good
let's see um albert albert it's serious
is he asking question
um he asks would you comment on the role
of randomness
in designing algorithms in the early
times of p versus np
yeah after uh
uh my mp complete newspaper i was
rewarded for the work by the
being made an administrator
and so i served as in an administrative
position
at berkeley for a while and
suspended my work on empty completeness
but i began to take up another
line of work uh studying the complexity
of algorithms
on random instances of graph theoretic
problems
and so uh um i looked at things like uh
constructing maximum matchings or uh
finding hamiltonian circuits in random
graphs and what density
is required and uh and again there are
critical
densities and one can derive
algorithms that are fast uh
up to a certain up to a certain density
so um so i worked on a number of
problems like this i worked on the
traveling salesman problem uh
where the cities are randomly
distributed over a
region of the plane and um
there were some very nice gratifying
results um
but i decided that the assumption of
erdashrini random graphs for example or
uniform distributions
over the plane were just not realistic
they didn't capture the
the nature of real applications
and so i decided after a while that
while it was fun doing this kind of
probabilistic analysis
that it wasn't probably going to
change the world because of the
artificiality of the probabilistic
assumptions
okay okay
um yeah so i'm not
speaking maybe speaking on albert's
behalf out of term but i'm just saying
he might have also been meaning the use
of random algorithms for solving
problems with high probability oh yeah
sure well i'm not sure i'm not sure
which amount yeah
yeah uh of course um
i i mentioned in my uh
and be in this paper that there were
three problem areas where i wasn't able
would have liked to settle the
complexity question you couldn't do it
one was primality the second one was
graph isomorphism
and the third one was linear programming
and in the case of primality um
of course the there was a
major major breakthroughs such as the
miller raven randomized algorithm and
that that was a very very striking
result
it left open the question of whether
primality was in p
and that was settled several years later
by
aks the trio from india
but for a while the the only polynomial
time algorithm
um known was randomized rather than
deterministic
there's also the question of quantum
algorithms where we don't know that p
in a quantum machine is the same as sp
on a turing machine with another
direction to explore
okay good let's see um there's several
questions here in the chat window
um so uh
well let's see let me take one at a time
so so thomas kochman asks um
when in the 60s or 70s did you
intuitively start expecting hawkins
intractability of resolution which came
in the 80s
so i guess this sort of implies you did
start expecting this so
you so the point was armand hawkins
proved that
it resolution requires exponentially
long proofs for things like the visual
principle
and the question is did did you have an
in
did you anticipate this in terms of
conjecturing it or expecting it or
was it no i don't think i had an opinion
about it i followed the work and i
i knew that they were attempts to
prove the pigeonhole principle required
uh exponential time in various settings
but i
didn't participate strongly
but i didn't have any intuitive
conjectures about
about that okay
okay uh and karen sockle has another
question
so let me just read it to you the
problem i see with current complexity
theory is that it generally ignores
problem structure
however that is defined is there a
reason why this is so
is it just hard to characterize the
problem structure
um i think he's coming back to your
question
he can he can correct me wrong of you
were saying how again
resolution and cdcl work unexpectedly
well
yeah and so this seems to be due to some
structure in the
in the inputs right so he's asking about
this
yeah um uh there's a
forthcoming book um
which uh which deals with um
um edited by a colleague at columbia
whose name
uh uh tim
what's kim's last name from
anyway tim
ralph garden yeah tim rough garden
tim has edited a book um dealing
with this issue of the behavior of
algorithms
for particular classes of inputs
and uh ways of
assessing the value of an algorithm
rather than its
worst case performance
so one can look at
algorithms operating on graphs with a
small tree width
or clustering problems with the side
assumption
that all of the near optimal solutions
are very similar to one another
um uh and and prove that
for those kinds of restrictions um on
the
problem space the algorithms perform
much better than
in the worst case
there are also results showing that
while the
simplex method um has those
uh failings that there are
contrived examples where it runs an
exponential time
uh one can show that if you
if even for those examples if you
randomly uh
alter the data infinitesimally you get
rid of the bad examples so the
examples are really a very low measure
in the space of all problem instances
so there this forthcoming uh book
uh edited by tim roughgarden
um will cover a large number of the
investigations of that kind i think it's
very
it's a very useful line of research
okay good uh
let's see another question uh ciaran
chiara mccreesh
asks the following question in your ns
in your nsf report from 1996
on the theory of computing goals and
directions
you said the theory community had to
recognize the importance of algorithm
engineering do you think they have done
so
um yeah i mean there
are many lines of investigation i think
which
um uh
take it and take into account the um
details of the platforms and what on
which um
algorithms are taking place whether they
take place in the cloud
um um
um there
i mean there are many lots of details
about making algorithms really work well
and measuring them properly
um the uh
there was also i'm not sure if i'm
answering direct
exactly the question um but there's a
feeling that one should really focus on
algorithms that are worst
quadratic in their running times because
we're getting so many data sets are so
large now
that any algorithm whose imports are
drawn consists of a large data set
really has to run
low polynomial time rather than
polynomial time in general
there's a lot of work on sublinear
algorithms streaming algorithms
many different directions that may be
suitable depending on the
circumstances where the computation is
happening
in terms of algorithm engineer
engineering
in terms of writing code that works well
i don't write code so i can't comment on
that
okay good uh ryan williams has a
question
uh it's a bit long i guess i can read it
so he says
this question is a bit vague but it is
it is it is relevant
in complexity theory running time is
or was the most precious resource that
is studied in
tremendous detail compared to other
resources an algorithm might consume
do you think this was an inevitable
development
manual blum and i used to argue about
this and he suggested that complexity
theory
could have quote developed in other
directions and running time just
happened to be what people were
interested in
decades ago i thought time was central
to the entire
idea of complexity theory
i i i think time is central
uh it's natural um
i suppose there's there should be some
measures of the
complexity of the algorithm just in
terms of its uh
concept the conceptual difficulty of
grasping it
or the difficulty of realizing it as a
program
i also love manuel's axiomatic approach
and the
amazing theorems that come there for
arbitrary complexity measures
but i would tend to side with ryan and
think that
uh time is probably the resource you
think of
most maybe there are resources related
to communication
when a problem is done in a truth in a
distributed setting
it should be considered the number of
bits that the different parties to the
algorithm have to exchange
good all right let me see one last
question is a
maybe a easy one then it was um
vj ganesh asked earlier is there a
resource on the history of complexity
theory that you would recommend
on the history of complexity theory
um
no there's a there's a nice book about
the pnp story that has been published
um
again help me out with the name it's um
lance farknow yeah yes lance ford now
yes i i've enjoyed uh reading that
because
that's a nice uh
uh ex exposition for the public
but i think you're asking about a major
uh
uh a
technical overview
of course they're very good texts on
complexity theory by various authors
yeah uh let's see i guess the name of
the book is the golden ticket is that
correct
golden ticket yeah yeah yeah
okay
yeah i would say a lot of the things you
talked about today are
aren't aren't studied that actively you
know like uh
time all alternatives to time complexity
for instance now and things like that
but
the field is as as as it should have
moved on to
new things right but uh but
you know well i would single out
communication complexity as a
rather thriving area sort of the number
of bits that alice and bob have to
exchange
in order to to uh make a decision
that seems very well motivated
good all right well thank you again so
much on behalf of everyone i wish there
was some way we could all
applaud but i'll do it for the group
again so uh that was a wonderful talk i
found it very inspiring
and um it was great to hear all this so
so we're gonna take a four minute break
till the half hour um so if you need to
stretch your legs or whatever and then
our next speaker will start um and um
vijay mentions he's just googling right
now he's found a book
on google called the history of
mathematical logic by dirk vandal and
john dawson and aki kano
and akika mori
okay so we'll take a three minute break
now and we'll be right back
okay thank you again that was a great
talk